okay so this is going to be an opening
traps video and an opening repertoire
video
all in one
it's also going to be a response video
to gotham chess's
how to crush people with the kerocon
which was actually a pretty good video
um i'll leave a link to in the
description
where he covers how to play the caro
khan as black
but today we're going to look at how to
actually play against the caro khan
and we'll see a lot of tricky trappy
lines
um stemming from the main variation i
recommend which is the two knights
attack
and this opening is
not only really popular among like the
super gm level it's very reputable
but at the club kind of amateur level
which i assume is most people watching
this video
kind of sub 2000 maybe even sub 1200
there's a lot of ways for black to go
wrong and
for the players who are unprepared as
black
it's very easy to stumble into the the
countless traps and that's what we'll
cover in this video
and for those that want to analyze on
their own i will be leaving a link to
the leachat study where i outline the
repertoire every chapter has its own
main variation and uh and annotations
so before we get into all the tricks and
traps and analysis i do want to thank
the sponsor of today's video which is
audible if you're not familiar with them
which you should be by now but they are
the world's largest audiobook platform
and the thing i love about audible is
the fact that i don't have to sit down
and actually read a physical book i can
listen across all my devices whether i'm
taking long walks listening while
washing dishes or even listening in the
shower
and it's one of the main ways i stay
educated
and informed about all the areas that
i'm interested in these days now i'll
give a sneak peek to my audible library
and one book i want to recommend it's
called deep work by cal newport it's not
only helped me with my overall chess
improvement when i want to study chess
i'm able to to find an environment where
i can maximize my effectiveness and
productivity but it's also helped me
with content creation and even recording
videos like this where i can get in the
zone and be as productive and efficient
as possible
so if you want to get this audiobook or
any other audiobook of your choice be
sure to click the link in the
description
audible.com
i am rosen or text i am rosen to 500 500
to get a 30 day free trial and with that
let's get back to the chess okay so as
you probably know by now the two knights
attack is e4 c6
knight f3 d5 knight c3
it doesn't actually matter which order
you develop your knights
um because almost every kerocon player
will play this and this
so as long as you can get to this
position this marks the beginning of the
two knights attack
where things can already branch out
depending what black does
and in this video we'll look at the most
common moves for black including pawn
takes pawn bishop g4 knight f6 and d4
and i'll be sure to time stamp
everything below
oops didn't mean to hit my mic sorry
mike
i also have everything here in the study
which should be relatively organized so
feel free to hop around chapter chapter
but i do encourage people to watch all
the way through to see all the
traps which are not maybe the most so
well known
especially to gotham chess viewers
so let's hop in to
the first chapter here
which is actually one of the most common
traps that kerocon players will fall
into
and it happens after
d takes e4 knight takes e4
and bishop f5
and a lot of players will play this move
bishop f5 because uh the mainline carol
khan
if we look at pawn d4
d5 knight c3 takes takes bishop f5
is like the main main line
that most carol khan players are trained
to play
the tricky thing about
this move order
with white delaying
pawn d4
and
accelerating the development of the
knights
it turns out bishop f5 is a mistake
because white has knight g3
and there's ways to get continual
initiative
against especially the bishop and just
the king side in general
and we're going to see a very nice line
here how the play flows really really
nicely for white
most of the time what happens is black
will get just an awful position
within the first 10 moves
so just to show um if we look at the
database bishop f5 has been played over
100 000 times and this move does deserve
a question mark this is a clear mistake
and after knight g3 bishop g6 will play
through the most common line
uh for both sides pawn h4
and here white is already threatening to
trap the bishop with pawn h5 this means
black pretty much has to
move the h pawn most of the time black
will play h6
and here we we keep improving our
position while making threats
we can start with knight e5
there's a reason why we don't play h5 so
soon the idea of knight e5 of course we
want to take
and really destroy black's king's height
pawn structure but we're also opening
the diagonal for the queen
so that after bishop h7
we can go straight in and play queen h5
already threatening mate
and now we're putting black in kind of
an awkward position there's really not
too many ways to defend the checkmates
117 people
got mated right away uh with this
most common move here is pawn g6
which is incredibly ugly given it just
prevents the bishop from having any life
in the position
another attempt is queen d5
this is even worse than g6 because after
bishop c4
white is skewering the queen and the f
pawn and his winning material uh
coordination of white's position is
really nice the queen defends the knight
knight defends the bishop bishop skewers
stuff
and black is already just completely
losing here
so
let's take a look at g6
because here we have a really nice oh no
my queen opportunity we actually don't
need to move the queen on h5
we can develop the bishop
and say oh no my queen
518 people have taken the queen
resulting in
bishop takes f7 checkmate
um
yeah and some some reasonably high rated
players actually had this once
against a 2000 plus rated player pretty
sure it was a bullet game
but
goes to show black does have to be
careful
uh most people will play e6 here
and now the trickiest move to play
is
not queen f3 which obviously looks
attractive which would threaten
checkmates but even trickier is queen e2
with more of a subtle threat
and
of course if we play queen f3 white's
still better uh there's none f6
but when we play queen e2
we are threatening to take on f7
and then take on e6
with complete destruction
of
black's kind of king safety
and if black plays
any of these so-called kind of natural
moves bishop g7 knight f6 bishop d6
knight t7
all of these moves
are blunders
due to the idea of knight takes f7 and
queen e6
so
the most common move actually two of the
most common moves are just blunders here
bishop g7 we take
and if we see how this plays out if king
takes
white is just mean by force king f8 and
queen f7
very similar
is if knight f6
we take on f7
and we can see just based on the win
percentage
700 plus games white is winning 100 of
them
after king takes takes and queen f7
again
is checkmate
so a lot of ways for black to go wrong
um
even even going into this position if
black is careful and plays
let's say queen c7 is one of the better
moves queen c7 or queen e7 to reinforce
f7
white can continue with pawn d4
and even though white's not up any
material
the position is just really really nice
for white
uh harmonious development meanwhile
black's only developed minor piece is
just complete garbage on each seven
white is ready to continue with bishop
f4 to pressure the queen probably
queenside castling and we'll have a lot
of
a lot of nice opportunities going into
the middle game
so going back to
where black went wrong was to move
bishop f5
most likely if black plays this move
they'll stumble into the line that we
just saw
it's quite forcing and white has a
significant advantage even after
pawn h4
so there's a few other things to know uh
regarding
this position
if black plays bishop g4
there is an opportunity to transpose
into what we just saw white can play h3
now if black takes we're happy to take
back and just have a lean development
if that maintains a pin
we can play knight g3 hitting the bishop
again
and at bishop g6
we can play pawn h4 and this is exactly
what we just saw previously
white did lose a tempo playing h3h4 but
black also lost some time moving the
bishop a bunch of times
and this could go into
the same exact line oh no my queen
and um
once you start reviewing this enough the
lines should
become very natural to remember because
pretty much every move is a threat
once the bishop develops either to f5 or
to g4 we just keep throwing punches
until we get a really nice position
let's move on to some alternatives for
black from this position
and moving on to chapter three
we're going to look at one of the lines
that levy recommends in his caro khan
video
the so-called tartakower variation
um which is knight f6
and i believe tartakow variation is
actually when white has a pawn in d4
and no knight on f3
but uh yeah the plan for black is
hoping white takes on
f6
generally black will take back and then
have easy development
with a very stable kind of defensive
pawn structure
on the king side
now the move i recommend against knight
f6
is
what i would consider by far the
trickiest move
is to play queen e2
which looks a bit odd at first
generally you don't want to move your
queen to block in
your own bishop
but in this case it is played with a
clear kind of positional threat
of taking on f6
and then preventing black from taking
back with the epawn
so in cases where black develops
we can take
and if black has to take the g pawn
we've made some progress with kind of
damaging black structure very unlikely
black will castle
on the king side and meanwhile like in
complete development
generally i
like to play a move like d3 restricting
the bishop then go for the king side
fiancado where we can eventually castle
and with the fiancado the g-file is not
really an issue because we're going to
have a very very solid
kind of formation on the king side
and meanwhile we have ideas of knight h4
to harass the bishop
and further ideas of fiance the other
bishop on the queen side
with some nice mental gameplay so i
don't want to give like too many
specific lines because there's a lot of
ways things can branch out but this is
just one
kind of simple setup for white where
white can get a very solid position
going into the middle game
now if black
doesn't play bishop f5
and plays
what is this a fifth most common move
knight b d7
and i'm hiding the opening explorer
because i don't want to spoil
the next move for white
this is uh
the worst move in the position for black
i saw over 1700 players have played this
as black
it's now white to move
and checkmate in one
i would hope most viewers
already see the move for white
but if you haven't seen it by now
the move is
knight d6 checkmates
actually over 3000 people have walked
into this there are probably some
transpositions but knight t6 is a really
nice middle game smothermate
if you haven't seen this pattern before
it can come as a real shock but
goes to show that
if you're a kerocon player you have to
be really really careful of not getting
smother mated
in the middle game
so going back
the most common move
for black is to take on e4
and this will actually bring us to
chapter four
so real quick review unites attack
uh we're focusing on d takes e4 knight
takes e4
levy's recommendation
and now queen e2 is setting up the the
tricks potential tricks along the e file
and now after takes takes one of the
main plans for black here
actually the most common move is to now
play knight d7
to bring this knight to f6 and to try to
attack the white queen
and here we can just complete
development bishop c4
knight f6
and this is another moment where we're
not going to move our queen
but we're going to make an even more
powerful counter threat
with the move knight e5
another case where we can say oh no my
queen
merged link below
and then we deliver checkmate on f7
so
just out of curiosity
uh yeah 647 people
mistakenly took the queen as black
and uh yeah good job to everyone who
delivered the mates wow some pretty high
rated players in the top games too
i assume these are bullet games but
still
this can potentially work against
2200 plus rated players so more commonly
after 95 black will play pawn e6
and this is where we do have to move our
queen back uh we can play queen e2
and here we have a position where white
is already ahead in development
and has very easy kind of development
going forward
the line i give here is bishop d6 we can
play d4 reinforcing the knight opening
the bishop
let's say black castles
take notes i'm
generally following the most common
moves for black so this is what you're
most likely
to get if you play this line and here i
recommend that white don't castle
kingside which would lead to a more
positional game let's start with a move
bishop g5
and then prepare to castle queenside
and then go for the kingside attack
and from this position the most common
move is pawn h6
and here i recommend playing pawn h4
this is by far
the most aggressive approach
and this is setting up the so-called
fishing pole trap
where if black takes
it leads to very very big problems for
black along each file
if the knight tries to save itself
either knight h7
actually wherever the light goes from
this position
white's going to respond with queen h5
with what i believe is force mate if we
look at knight h7
queen h5
i don't see how black avoids the
checkmate here
if rook e8
we could take the knight but even matter
is taking on f7
and then another kind of semi-smothered
mate with the knight
um
yeah very similar if i hear
we play queen h5 and there's no stopping
queen h8 checkmate
so uh the bishop on g5 is poisonous
after pawn h4
and we can see based on
the
the wind percentage for white
even after pawn h4
white is winning 77
of the time so it goes to show that it's
it's already difficult on a practical
level for black
uh most common move is bishop e7 here
and this is where we can queenside
castle
and get a very pleasant kind of
attacking middle game going forward
again if black takes we're happy to open
each file and have the prospect of
mating really quickly
if black doesn't take um we have ideas
of playing g4 eventually taking on
f6 and then going for g5 to then later
open the g file
if queen a5 is played pretty sure we can
go ahead and play
wow engine is already giving plus four
for white yeah you can maybe explore
with engine moves i like the move g4
though
uh with a plan of taking and going for
g5
and
just another position where white can
get a really nice attack from very early
on
okay so i think it's time to look at
some alternatives for black
going back to
the start of the two nights attack
we did just look at several different
lines after d takes e4
now it's time to look at
what happens if black plays pawn d4
which looks like one of the more
kind of threatening aggressive
approaches for black kicking the knight
right away away from the centralized c3
square
and this is a line whenever i encounter
i usually look forward to playing
because after 92
we counter attack the pawn black pretty
much has to play pawn c5 here
and now we can develop the knight to g3
and even though we spent already three
moves with this knight in the opening
black has only pushed pawns so far
arguably black is a bit overextended and
white has some very easy development
with potential later to attack on the
king's side with the already well-placed
kingside knights so i don't want to dig
too deeply into this variation but i do
want to give one example line show a few
traps and show that white's play is
pretty fun and simple
from here on out
so most common move is knight c6 for
black
we can put the bishop on c4
targeting the f7 pawn
and now one trap here is that if black
plays
pawn e5
which is the most common move
we can start with pawn d3
and then if black plays again the most
common move knight f6
this is already a blunder
let's give this a question mark
now it's white to move
and win material and this seems like an
odd type of blunder because it looks
supernatural
just developing getting ready to castle
but the problem for black
lies in the weakness of the f7 pawn
white can very simply
bring the knight to g5
now attacking f7 twice
and there's no good way
for black to defend the pawn without
losing material
uh maybe the best try is bishop e6
but then we can take recommend taking
with knights keep our light squared
bishop and then be up upon
also with the light square domination
so
if we look at the opening database
there have been
450 games where white has seized the
opportunity with knight g5
very high winning percentage for for
white
so for this reason instead of pawn e5 uh
it's better for black to play pawn e6
even though this blocks in black's own
lights for bishop it does blunt the
power of white slight square bishop
and then play can develop pretty
naturally from here white can play d3
knight f6
castling
a6 is a pretty common idea for black
going for pawn b5
to target the bishop and the general
rule whenever black prepares to play b5
white can respond with a4
just a prophylactic move also attempting
just to kind of clamp down there's
potential later to play bishop d2 and a5
to have
uh the two pawns fixed on the queen side
we also give some
additional room for the bishop opening
the a2 square black usually will play
bishop e7 here
white can go ahead complete development
and then if castling
there is kind of a cool idea i recommend
here to play knight g5
which might look odd at first
and already there is there's only one
game from this position
but the idea of knight g5 is just to
clear the way for the f pawn
and the way that white can actually
initiate an attack here
is to storm on the king side with
potentially f4 and then f5
and meanwhile if black tries to kick the
knights with h6
we can very calmly drop back to h3
and then be ready to advance with f4
if black plays e5 we play f4
and we're not afraid of bishop takes h3
we can just take back
and then very soon have both the g and
the f files to work with common to play
king
h1 potentially rook g1
also bring our queen in
there's cases where we'll play f5 have
our bishop targeting h6
keep in mind our other bishop is
very nicely placed along the light
square diagonal
and if we turn on engine here
it will favor white and i think from a
practical standpoint it's just much much
more enjoyable to play for white
so of course this is just one example
line there's different ways for
the position to branch out
after pawn d4 and c5 knight g3 but
hopefully what i gave in terms of a
development scheme for white and just
offer a very pleasant and enjoyable
middle game position
so let's move on to
a
slightly more rare and trappy line for
this one we're gonna see black playing
bishop to g4
which levy did mention in his video
but he didn't mention
the line that i'm about to recommend
which is bishop to e2
not the most common move
but a really really tricky move and if
lock's not careful it can be very easy
to lose material right away
now on the surface this move is actually
very natural
we break the pin
against the knight white prepares the
castle
and completes the kingside development
way before black has even touched
anything on the king's side
and on top of this
one of the most attractive looking moves
for black
is actually a blunder here
that move being pawn to d4
now this move looks attractive because
the knight no longer has the e2 square
to draw back to
it looks like the knight has to go
either back to b1 or to a4
but it turns out white has a really nice
tactical trick is just to take the pawn
on d4
and even though the knight appears to be
undefended
we are attacking the bishop on g4 so if
takes takes
white just won a pawn
and if
black tries to trade on e2 first
white can very simply take back with the
knights and again white one the central
pawn on d4
has a very clean
pawn advantage going into the middle
game
so this is a very prevalent trap
not only stemming from this opening but
in in different types of openings
whenever you see
uh this combination of pieces if a pawn
ever lands on d4 you want to be hyper
aware of the possibility of just taking
it with your knight
so for this reason it's better for black
of course not to play d4 but to play a
move like e6
and then here white can very simply
castle complete development
take note if black plays g4 again
we still have the same
trap knight takes d4 white wins the pawn
same exact tactic
and then going forward from here if
black plays knight f6
really trying to pressure the e pawn
i can recommend
uh diverting attention attack the bishop
trying to provoke bishop takes f3
after which we can take support the pawn
also getting the bishop hair
and if bishop to h5
there is kind of a cool idea i
discovered
when uh when preparing this file to play
the move knight e5
offering the bishop trade
and assuming black takes we take with
queen
reinforcing e pawn
and now we have ideas of lunging our f
pawn forward
also of course moving our pawn to d4
and if black now plays d4 we can simply
retreat knight b1
um i know it looks a little bit ugly but
we're actually setting up a cool idea
here if black plays the most natural
move bishop d6 we can now take on f7
clearing the way
for the fork on e5
and this actually turns out to be a
trade we're guaranteed to win back a
minor piece for a pawn if takes
takes
then white is
slightly preferred by the engine we've
taken away box hassling rights very
likely we'll play d3 develop the bishop
develop the knights attack along e-file
and have a pleasant game going forward
now for those that want even more
analysis
on this tricky bishop e2 line
i can highly recommend
checking out jonathan trons's video
which is linked in the leachat study
i'll link it below in the description as
well he has a 30 minute plus video
covering a lot of the branches of this
line he goes way more in depth he also
likes to cover like really tricky
offbeat openings so uh be sure to check
out his video if you want to learn this
specific variation in much more depth
okay so we are reaching the final
chapter
of this video of this leachat study
is what to do against knight to f6 on
move three
and i will admit originally when
planning like what to show in this video
i was going to leave out this move
because it's not the most popular move
if we look up the position on the chess
knight f6 is fourth most popular
but then upon
doing a little bit of research
i actually discovered some really nice
gambit style lines to play
so i figured this is just extra bonus
and for those watching hopefully this
will give you an even more
kind of robust repertoire
if you do encounter this move from time
to time
so the move i recommend here is on e5
hitting the knights
forcing the knight to either retreat
or move forward knight e4 is the most
popular move
but first we'll quickly look at knight
d7
this allows white to play a really cool
gambit which is supported by the engine
actually if we turn on stockfish here
the top engine move
is to just gamut our e pawn
pawn e6
the point being after f takes e6
we're not gonna go for any immediate
tactics we're just gonna go for
positional compensation
uh i recommend playing d4
and
this structure even though black has
three center pawns the pawns are a bit
stuck
and it's really hard to complete
development for black given that the
pawns are kind of just in the way
of the minor pieces so the most common
move for black is to bring the knight
back to f6 and then white can complete
development with bishop d3
and honestly if you know how to get to
this position you don't need to know too
much
more specific lines
it's just a matter of knowing some basic
ideas going into the middle game
very often white wants to clamp down on
this e5 square
develop the bishop f4 put it on an e5
castle eventually bring a rook to f1
another idea is if black ever plays pawn
g6
we can go straight ahead and play pawn
h4
going for the immediate attack against
these black kingside pawns
and there's actually a really funny line
here if black goes for bishop to g7
we can play pawn h5 this is actually one
of the more common lines
stemming from this e6 gamut
and if knight takes h5
a lot of players will play rook h5
which uh
is still computer approved
but the engine will give an even
stronger move here for light
pawn to g4
forcing the knight to move back
and then really nice idea bishop h6
trying to remove one of the main
defenders on the king side
after takes takes
if black
is greedy and tries to win a pawn
we have the nice move rook h4
with a double threat of rook takes g4
and also bishop takes g6
taking advantage of h file pin
so this is just a nice tidbit of opening
preparation
i i discovered when looking through this
variation
very flowing line like keeps initiative
throughout
and gets a position where even though
you're down material
the engine prefers white and
black is
is very soon about to just crumble so
going back to
the main line
if black plays a more popular move
knight t4
i can recommend
the third most popular move here knight
takes e4
which is going to result in yet another
gambit after pawn takes e4
knight g5
black can win this pawn with queen d4
but we're not afraid we're going to play
d3
pawn takes e3 bishop takes d3
queen takes e5
and now bishop to e3
and at the cost of a pawn
we have our minor pieces developed
we're ready to castle
we have the two
center files to work with very soon of
course we want to bring a rook to e1
probably eventually queen f3 or queen h5
bring another rook to d1
and if black gets greedy and grabs a b2
pawn white can very simply castle
the engine
already gives white a very big plus
and i don't want to go
too much in depth but i just wanted to
show this as inspiration
especially
for those that really enjoy
giving away material for quick
compensation and initiative
this line is computer approved and
there's lots of opportunities to explore
more deeply
so just quick recommendation if you do
encounter knight f6
and knight e4 okay so i think we've
covered the the main bases of course
there's always more to cover so i'm sure
there's going to be questions from
people in the comments
so if you do have questions about any of
the lines i covered feel free to leave a
comment below
feel free to check out the leachat study
and use the opening explorer
or stockfish to analyze further
and good luck in your games against the
caro khan
and if you enjoyed this video and want
to see more kind of opening trap style
videos
let me know what openings you would like
me to cover in the future
and with that i will see you in the next
video